hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that i have never seen
before
uh it's from a simultaneous exhibition
from 1996 that
gary caspar was holding in israel uh he
had it
against 25 players and they were well
they were very very strong
as you'll see later on now before we
check out the game
the game comes as a suggestion from
shamal makov so uh thank you for that
i like i said i i haven't seen the game
and i was not aware of this event that
it had happened i
i'm not aware of all events but it's
just that uh this one featuring such a
nice game
uh you know i one would think that i
would have seen it by now
and there's been a lot of talk about it
after especially after this game it's
been all over the news in every
newspaper
uh you know i will be i'll even put a
link to the new york times um
uh that was published after this game
was played and there's a even a
youtube link with actual footage from
this event uh where you can check out um
well uh what's been going on so this is
a
nice photo it's not from this event it's
actually from an event
two years ago where uh two of the uh
same opponents met and here you can see
a very interesting position on the board
i was also a simultaneous exhibition and
this game ended in a draw
however this game that i'm showing you
now didn't most certainly did not end in
a draw
so without further ado let's check it
out so kasparov with the white pieces
opens with e4
as one usually does when he holds a
simultaneous exhibition he's white on
all boards and all of his 25 opponents
have the black pieces
so e4 we have e6 by sharansky we have d4
and d5 and nathan sharansky at the
moment that this game was played was the
minister of industry and trade
in israel so here uh kasparov grabs on
the e5 with e captures on the e5 going
for the exchange variation of the french
e captures that's not a captures e
captures on d5 and now
just continues developing with knight to
f3 uh we have
knight to f6 and now bishop to d3 now we
often mention when there is an exchange
variation of the french that famous
quote
that mikhail tal said that uh if you
play the
uh the exchange variation against the
french then you uh
you you basically don't want a win uh
that's not how the quote actually goes
it goes more like um
uh i can't really remember but it's like
uh you you
if you're only satisfied uh with that
with a draw with the white pieces then
you're probably going to lose the game
so here uh we have bishop to e7 and
kasparov now plays h3 we have knight to
c6 and already here
after kasparov makes his uh seventh move
he plays a3
we have a position that has never
occurred before or after this game was
played
so after move seven we have a completely
new game
and here sharansky goes knight to e4 so
what do you play here caspar
of course strikes in the center he plays
c4 now the pawn is pressured if you
capture you lose the knight here
we have bishop to f5 and here because
power just castles we have d
captures an e uh on c4 now that the
knight is defended here
bishop captures and now black also
castles and here
kasparov makes a very interesting
decision he doesn't continue development
with some like knight to c3 or maybe
uh rook to e1 he goes d5 he grabs some
more space in the center but
this as you'll see in the game really
does uh
wonders for black so here knight to a5
attacking the bishop on c4 it's
undefended bishop to a2
because kasparov keeps the bishop on
this long diagonal and
now c5 asking do you want to capture on
c6 alpha
or do you want to not do that and keep
your past pawn because paro of course
really enjoys his protected past pawn so
he just continues developing we
rook the e1 and now comes a move that
really uh well really puts
a lot of problems for white uh here he
plays c4
and now the problem is how do you
develop here with white this bishop now
isn't really doing anything the pawn is
nicely defended here
uh you can't really play something like
b4 or b3 because the knight
defends the b3 square you could play
something like this but then just comes
c
captures on b3 and it doesn't matter
that the queen and the bishop are
defending it because for example bishop
captures and queen to b6
now with a double attack here uh on the
bishop and also the queen and the knight
are attacking the f2 pawn because the f2
pawn is now very weak so here
white is just lost so what can kasparov
do here well to play this he would have
to play
a super passive move he would have to
play something like bishop to d2
and then we'd get some like bishop to f6
attacking the pawn here and after we
defended this now comes knight to c5 and
now
with these two knights controlling b3
this knight controlling d3 the bishop
controlling d3
again it's playable but very very very
good for black
so here kasparov not wanting to play
such a passive position played knight to
d2 but
this allows black uh to start uh the
attack
uh so feel free to pause the video here
and try to figure out how to how to
start the attack here while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
doing it i know all of you all of you
played it because it's i mean it's
it's there uh so for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
knight captures an f2 of course we're
going to play this as now bishop the c5
check is coming and
the king is out of its uh uh well out of
his house
so here we have king captures on f2 and
now bishop the c2 with
check so what do you play here here
kasparov played rook to e3 he decided to
give
give back a little bit of material to
avoid
well to avoid going up the board but
going up the board that doesn't really
help white all that much because here
after queen to d6 check again you really
have nothing to play for
uh if you play king to h4 then queen to
f4 check and you're getting checkmated
g4 we're gonna play bishop to f2 check
and after the king moves g6 will just be
checkmate
so what you would have to do after queen
to d6 check you'd have to play something
like 95 which uh okay blocks the check
but now
uh we just bring the rook in rook 8 to
e8 with a double attack on the
knight and again this is coming there is
no defending this
uh not a lot you can do here you could
bring another knight here knight to f3
but then we just
attack the pin piece with f6 and if you
try running away with the king
we're just gonna capture and now again
you do not want to allow any discoveries
so probably rook carter's queen captures
king the h1
and it seems like white survived but c3
completely ruins uh white's day uh
there's the problem of just c captures
on b2 which wins
even more material and if you capture
this then comes queen captures on c3
and now how do you how do you uh defend
this the bishop cannot move
uh the the rook is under attack or rook
to b1 doesn't really help any
if rook to b1 the bishop is attacking it
you can just play captures and then
bishop captures is just uh
again a winning position for black so
here after bishop the c5
kasparov did not want to start running
with the king he played
rook to e3 he wants to give back some
material to
uh to help out with the defense and this
is a very happily accepted bishop
captures an e3 with
check king captures and now rook the e8
with
check bringing in another attacker with
check uh here
sharansky could have played queen to d6
uh queen to b6 would
check this is even more deadly as it
prevents the king from
going king f2 king to g1 here the king
would have to go
up the board and only now queen to d6
check and this is now much much deadlier
uh because now you don't really you
don't really have a good move
if you go something like king to e3 then
queen to g3 is coming and then
you are not hiding your king anywhere
for for the rest of the game
and if you accepted the bishop sacrifice
then rook 8 to e8 and now the king is
within grasp of the black pawns there's
uh no no escaping this
if you start running away we just play
f5 checking h4 queen f4 check and now
again g4 rook to f6 and now rook to h6
will be checkmate
and there is no defense against this so
after king captures an e3
uh this was uh a bit more precise
however
rook the e8 check was played and now
king to f2 now kasparov very happily
starts running away with his king king
queen capture sunday 5 was played in
king the g1 so this
gives a new life to the position and now
maybe kasparov can survive this
rook 8 to d8 but again what do you play
here the bishop does absolutely nothing
the knight cannot move
uh you you can't really develop here so
kasparov
basically does the only thing he can
king to h1
and now b5 cementing this pawn on c4 and
now the knight can move the knight is no
longer needed here and now we're going
to bring the knight into the game as
well
so here queen to f1 unpinning but
again not really doing all that much yes
now the knight can move but
the knight has nowhere to move too
that's that's a really big problem
so here bishop the d3 uh really
pushing that queen back to the corner
queen to g1
and now knight to c6 slowly but surely
starting to bring this
knight into the game uh we ignite the b1
now trying to activate uh his pieces a
little bit but
now knight to d4 and again what do you
play here
here caspar was happy to trade off some
of some of black's attackers but
this is his only active piece basically
so here
knight captures on d4 was played queen
captures and
now uh what do you play here uh if you
play queen captures on d4 and trade a
queen right away rook
captures uh what do you what do you play
here uh
knight tonight the c3 for example rook
to e1 check
and this bishop is never leaving here
this bishop can move
or even stay here we can bring the rook
into the game pick up the bishop it's
completely unplayable for white
so instead kasparov after this queen
captures on the uh on d4 he played
knight
to c3 but now again the position is
completely winning for black so feel
free to pause the video here and
win the game for uh nathan sharansky
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
finding the simplest and basically only
way to win this game
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's queen captain
g1 with check simple and elegant king
captures on g1
rook the e1 with check king to f2 and
now
rook d to e8 and now black has a variety
of moves how he can win this but
there's even a bigger bigger problem for
white because white does not have
a single move here you can't move the
bishop you lose the rook if you try and
move this bishop you don't really have a
square if you try bishop to b1
then we can capture this bishop and now
again you can't capture because your
rook is hanging
so what can you play here uh nothing
really here because power play knight
captures on b5
but he was also in this position after
playing this that kasparov just resigned
the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
to give you an example black can very
simply uh just play rook to f1 check for
example king g3 and now
rook the e1 and that's it there's no
defending this this is gonna fall
uh if you can grab a pawn we're just
gonna collect material here
captures captures and now it's
completely winning it's not
just that you're uh down uh down in
exchange for example uh like we have a
rook for a knight here but also this
bishop is just trapped and
this is happening there there's no
stopping this or or even this so we have
to bring the knight into the game
knight to c6 now the knight will come to
b4 to defend the bishop here
but still rook c2 is enough and now
after knight to b4 we're still going to
capture on b2
and there's again not much you can do
here we're just going to start
pushing our pass pawn if king f3 we're
going to play bishop to f1 even go after
these pawns g4 just c3
king e3 we're going to play rook to e2
with check now if the king goes in front
of the bishop then we're just going to
capture this with a discovery so the
king has to go up the board
c2 will be played and now we either
sacrifice the knight for the pawn and
then it's completely winning
or we try to hold knight d3 we cover the
c1 square
rook the e1 very sneaky guarding c1 and
now if knight captures we just bring a
queen into the game
and if uh white doesn't capture well
we're just going to eliminate the knight
and then bring the queen into the game
so let's say just capture c1 queen
and now black has a queen why doesn't
it's completely winning here for
for sharansky so incredible incredible
achievement
and as usual caspar was very angry after
losing this i
i think he lost three games and drew
four and all of those
seven uh seven opponents were russians
so he was uh
he was not very happy with that but like
i said there's a very very extensive
article that new york times published in
1996 after this game it will be in the
description below so do check it out
it's very very nice
uh and also uh here's a very nice uh
photo i've shown you this one this is
the two of them from 1994 but they've
also met once again
uh in 2018 uh as kasparov
said on his twitter twitter page uh here
nathan sharansky and i
are at the march 7th 2018 new york um
championship event honoring his life and
retirement as head of jewish
agency i asked the great ukrainian chess
composer edward um
ela elizian for a problem in homage to
sharansky's own life a trap knight
escapes the deliver mate so as you can
see
uh the two uh meet uh meet again
so uh this game is available on chess
games and it is
uh like a published game the one on this
photo
is not uh the one from 1994 where they
drew the game but
uh as it would seem the two of them
played two games uh one uh
was drawn and one was won by sharansky
uh so he
as i understand i did read a little bit
uh about him he was a very very
interested in chess he was a champion of
his uh
uh of his uh i don't know what exactly
but
he he was a very strong and um he
said that he as a young a young chess
player he was dreaming of becoming a
world champion so even though
he chose politics instead of chess he
still has i
it would seem a positive score against
uh uh
from world champion gary kasparov so
very very impressive stuff uh hope you
enjoyed that i really have enjoyed
this i have never seen this game and uh
i've never heard of mr sharansky so
uh very very impressive stuff uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very very nice suggestion
uh i would like to thank anirud kamadi
uh sandy
christoph diegleman and john austin for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh the prize next to the contribution
means that this contribution has been
made for the tournament
that is happening unleashes so these
contributions will be added to the prize
fund uh
that that i'm contributing so do join us
uh
we're gonna have a lot of fun i'm gonna
be streaming the event so that perhaps
you will have your own game showcased
uh and maybe you even uh you know do do
very well why wouldn't you you're a
great
chess player so as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
uh and whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day